[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à saint pierre si
chocolatées le premier bar à chocolat de
la réunion suivez-moi
donc je m'appelle renan de villèle j'ai
30 ans je suis né à la réunion et je
suis le gérant de chocolaté le premier
bar à chocolat ville qui a ouvert le 15
février 2021 j'ai travaillé dix ans dans
l'événementiel en métropole et j'ai pu
lui l'opportunité de travailler à la
réunion et là j'ai une totale remise en
question c'est de là que j'ai décidé
d'ouvrir le premier bar à chocolat de
lille et pour ça j'ai été aidé par
l'adie où j'ai suivi la formation jeu
devient entrepreneur qui m'a permis de
structurer mes idées et j'ai aussi la
cci qui m'a aidé au montage du dossier
pour le taz est aussi l' agence de pôle
emploi qui m'a donné deux trois conseils
pour mener à bien ce projet
donc chocolatées c'est comme un salon de
thé donc c'est un endroit convivial où
des clients se rencontrent discutent
autour de chocolat le principe est de
choisir ce que vous souhaitez manger ou
boire donc par exemple un chocolat chaud
chocolat frappé qui est roi une crête
une gaufre et d'y apposer le chocolat
que vous souhaitez donc vous avez devant
vous un huit cuves de chocolat fondu
forcément de chocolat très très bon qui
va du chocolat blanc jusqu au chocolat
noir
le principe c'est de choisir des
chocolats qui viennent de différents
endroits du monde d'équateur ou du ghana
hôte madagascar il faut savoir se sont
défaits ce qu'ils viennent de ces pays
là et c'est pas des mélanges à côté de
ça on fait aussi des thés glacés qu'on
fait infuser nous mêmes qu'on veut aussi
que ce soit un ensemble c'est à dire que
oui le chocolat est très bon mais note
d'offres ci est super bonne on a
vraiment travaillé la recette nos coûts
qui est aussi son très bon nous le dit
souvent nos crêpes sont réfléchies et
c'est tout un concept qui réfléchit
aussi autour de la décoration et voilà
on essaie de créer toute une ambiance et
une expérience pour le client final
performance économique parce que dès le
premier jour on n'était que deux on a
bien vu que ce n'est pas suffisant et au
bout du style j'aime jours on était six
personnes à travailler parce qu'on a dû
répondre à une forte demande un gros
buzz à travers les réseaux sociaux et
les médias de locaux une performance
humaine parce que du coup actuellement
on a deux salariés en cdd qui vont
passer en cdi à la fin de leur contrat
est également une alternance qui a 18
ans et du coup il a fallu trouver un
local tout mettre en place les travaux
recherche de fournisseurs et c'est donc
tout était nouveau actuellement donc au
bout de neuf mois d'ouverture on a 80
clients en moyenne qui génère un chiffre
d'affaires de 800 euros par jour et avec
un coefficient multiplicateur de 6,5 ces
chiffres sont pas doublés lorsque c'est
les vacances et les week-ends parce
qu'on a beaucoup plus ou moins et un
week-end on a dû refuser jusqu'à 256
seul on va plus vite ensemble on va plus
loin
[Musique]